you guys let's do this
put your hands together for Joey you're
doing home sick that was the raindrops
the [ __ ] watch bluebloods your bird back
[ __ ] you wanna know who are we
talking bird back you read up all and
[ __ ] bird back you can't get no
better this right now they're gonna
shoot a place up it's just [ __ ] walk
that's it yeah get around a little
surgery kids and kids actor wheel on
adderall [ __ ] the drug folks take the
stick I know we're Christian but [ __ ]
fiancee let's just make believe with
normal for tonight
take the [ __ ] ride alright people how
are you sir this [ __ ] drinking
how are you sir you on your fault we'll
go I don't give a [ __ ] how you sexy I
don't break the habit
Gazoo all right [ __ ] the Jews coffee
juice are you a little chilly
[ __ ] [ __ ] you driving out
where's your self-respect not soccer
and you wanna [ __ ] without dropping
[ __ ] [ __ ] I suck
are you gonna lose to while you read you
all right give me a potential low light
you all right don't you have some limits
make humans of your choosing a Caribbean
I got Shawn stop it you understand so
you just act like a [ __ ] Jew come on
through the Sandoz ha ha oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
the whole house you see somebody Jews in
Jersey beyond the diamonds blood
diamonds having up a black finger
diamond from there
the only other me to know a house or not
picture of Jesus getting beat up
that's my uncle
one of those deep [ __ ] I bring up will
smack Jesus Jews and [ __ ] you really
haven't you fill up belly full one half
a bucket below but nobody goes what a
[ __ ] up Jews those are Hasidic Jewish
distinct these I like those together -
no boy those [ __ ] chase you for
a year when I first came to do with my
dual five West 88th Street these little
[ __ ] white kids with torches of basil
Irish kids then it go I said
these [ __ ] took it to the next
level they took an egg and put a pin
hole in it and come under that bed for a
week flat [ __ ] slow rate that I
read to the fungi and a kitchen and you
slip your shoes for this confuses the
[ __ ]
this guy with chases from 88th Street
the [ __ ] 140 and I only wonder like
at that time there was new pair of
sneakers
there was converse and broke-ass that's
it and broke hence was always that big
thing was dissolving you can jump higher
you can run faster [ __ ] you I want to
get those knees I'm sorry I love you too
that's it No